Government is not a monolithic
thing, which is your enemy.
It's a multitudinous thing, which is your enemy.
Our dream was to enable the
future of human freedom.
In the early 1990s, a group ofmathematicians, misfits, hackers,and hobbyists
came together around ashared belief that the internet would either demolish artificial walls
or lay the groundwork for an Orwellian state.
We can prevent the Ministry of Truth.
They saw a branch ofmathematics called cryptography
as a weapon against central planning andsurveillance in this new virtual world.
And what is a cypherpunk? Cypherpunks are cryptography activists.
The more I realize how it was a
really pivotal technology for society.
The National Security Agency
declared the unrestrained publicdiscussion
of cryptographic research
threatened our national security.
I saw this as the critical fork in the
road for the future of human freedom.
Coming up, Reason presents a four-part
series on a movement that foresaw both
the promise and the peril that lay ahead
when the internet upended the world.
It's like standing on top of the mountain
and seeing that this is out there.
You people who are here can say, "Okay, what kind of world do we reallywant to build?" And build it.
Imagine, if you will, sitting down toyour morning coffee, turning on yourhome computer to read the day's newspaper.
Well, it's not as far-fetched as it may seem.
The freedom issues were very important to us.
This is a sample of what you
can order through your computer.
It combines the power of your computer
with the convenience of your telephone.
We saw that information technology could create
a 1984 style tyrannical top-down control society.
Or it could develop into something that is
a decentralized enabler of human freedom.
And even back then, our dream was to
enable the future of human freedom.
In the late 1980s at the dawn of the online
age, a group of young computer scientists inSilicon Valley
started grappling with what
this new technology would mean for society.
We took a look at the potential of computer
systems and saw that for everything aboutcivilization
that enables it to work,
we can enable it to work much better.
The most influential figure in what
would become the cypherpunk movement
was the physicist, Tim May, who envisioned the
future internet as a place for what he would dub
"crypto-anarchy," where lawbreakers,
radicals, and political dissidents
could shield their activities from
government surveillance and control.
People doing things that
didn't require permissions
from anyone because the people were
untraceable, it couldn't be stopped.
But there was another group that saw the
potential of computers to remake society
gradually from within, by decentralizing commerce
and improving the dissemination of knowledge.
They were dubbed the High-Tech Hayekians
because their worldview was influenced by
the work of Austrian economist, Friedrich Hayek.
The fundamental insights of Hayekian economics was
how separately formulated plans tend to
mesh well.
And we saw electronic media as a enabler of coordination of a complexity thatthe world previously was really not capable of.
The clash of visions between theHigh-Tech Hayekians,
who wanted tobuild a borderless, frictionless, globalmarketplace,
and the crypto-anarchist who saw the internet as a technologicalmeans of undermining all governments,
set the course for the cypherpunk movement.
If May was the father of crypto-anarchy,
the central figure for The High-Tech Hayekians
was the economist and entrepreneur, Phil Salin.
Now, if you own a personal computer,
we are told you can shop at home on
what's called The Electronic Mall.
It was a few years before the invention of the World
Wide Web but computer companies were offering
a new type of service in which customers
could connect through their phone lines
to post messages to a bulletin board,
check their horoscopes, or go shopping.
You can buy items from department stores
ranging from Nordstroms to Neiman
Marcus, all via computer screen.
Salin, whose outlook was shaped
by his careful reading of Hayek,
understood that these services weren't
merely a curiosity or a digital version
of the old mail order catalog, they were
the beginning of something that had thepotential
to one day erase national boundaries
through trade and undermine government power.
In a prescient 1991 essay, he foresaw
how the internet would change the world by 1995,
2000, and beyond. The static
role of store and shopper,
seller and buyer, author and reader, systems
defined by their one-way information flows
will be replaced by new forms of media
enabling two-way information flows.
Before getting involved with computers,
Salin had run a private rocket company
and had coauthored a congressional study
critical of NASA's wasteful spending.
But in his view, there was continuity between
his interest in space travel and computing,
because in both industries, technology's
purpose was to drive down the transactioncosts
that impede human activity,
making it feasible to explore newfrontiers,
and interact in ways that would
otherwise be prohibitively expensive.
Now, thanks to breakthroughs in computing, the
ability to buy or obtain exactly the informationyou need
when you want it, in the form youwant it, is about to explode at a speedunmatched since the invention of printing.
ButSalin was foremost an entrepreneur, and in the mid-1980s,
he set out to launch one of thoseplatforms for buying and selling information.
He called it the American
Information Exchange or AMIX.
This business that we're doing is to
make possible a new kind of thing,
which is being able to buy
and sell information online.
AMIX was a radical idea in the mid1980s.
Users could buy or sell adviceabout the real estate market, writingsoftware, or what companies to invest in.
Now, you can say to somebody, so
it's like eBay, or like Priceline,or like Amazon.
When we triedto explain this to people, they simply couldn't get it, they could not wrap their heads around this.
Some of them, I think, couldn't imagine the computationalend of it. Milton Friedman didn't get it.
Though it was similar in ways to the online
marketplaces that would launch a decade later,
AMIX was more than just an idea before its time.
What set it apart was it the
grounding in political philosophy
and its lofty goal of elevating individual
decision-making over central planning.
It was an instantiation of Austrian
economics. Now put into code and put online.
Something like this could have profound
human consequences. And that was the vision.
"A fluid transaction-oriented market system,
with two-way feedback." Salin wrote,
"would  result in crowding out monolithic,
mostly government bureaucracies."
We were laying the philosophical foundations
of what is e-commerce, that you can now have creative explosion.
It's going tochange the world. Yes, that's right.
Intermediating among large populations
of human beings through electronic means
results in all kinds of fascinating
emergent social behavior.
AMIX's chief architect was the pioneering software
engineer, Chip Morningstar,
who had come from a stint at George Lucas's production studio, wherehe oversaw the creation of Habitat,
which was one of the first online virtual communities.
After joining AMIX, Morningstar coauthored an essay
which argued that in building a world insoftware, detailed central planning is impossible.
The world is just more complicated. Peopleare more complicated, you cannot knowwhat all their goals are.
What you can do isyou can put them into an environment in whichcertain kinds of things are possible.
Whatyou can't do is tell people what they want.
Phil Salin, Mark Miller, and Chip Morningstar'sideas about how a future internet could decentralize society
inspired Tim May tofirst articulate a radically different vision.
May, who would go on to become the most
influential figure in the cypherpunk movement,
was introduced to Salin by
Morningstar in December of 1987.
Chip said, "There's this guy out in
Santa Cruz that you ought to talk to."
As a scientist at Intel, May had solved an issue affecting the reliability of the company's memory chips,
called the AlphaParticle problem.
Rich on stock options, he'd been spending his days at the beach,reading science fiction novels,
thinking about how networked personal computers could turn
some of their futuristic scenarios into reality.
So I met with Phil in Redwood City and he
described how AMIX would work. And I said,
"People aren't going to be selling meaningless
stuff like surfboard recommendations."
In May's view, AMIX could be useful
as a tool for undermining state power,
but only by shattering legal and social norms.
And I said, "It's going to be corporate
information. It's going to be bomber plansfor the B-1 bomber.
Who wants to buythat? A competitor or a company.
Who wants to sell that? Someone who
has access to that information.
It's two different types of libertarians.
He didn't understand the extent to which
you could benefit the world by lowering
transaction costs for everybody.
Like Salin and The High-Tech Hayekians, May sawthe personal computer as enabling technologyfor sweeping societal changes.
But he had a different vision of a virtual marketplace for any and all goods and services,
which he dubbed Black Net,or a technological means of undermining allgovernments.
On AMIX user activity was out in the open, but Black Net would be impervious to government tracking and surveillance.
And perhapsit would be a network with no owners at all.
Many people's first response would be to say
that Black Net won't be allowed to happen.
Perhaps, but technology would
probably make it inevitable.
If you don't physically meet the person ifyou don't even know what continentthey're on, you can't coerce them.
Tim May is a smart guy. He was great for
honing our ideas and technologies against.
But I think him as the shock jock for cypherpunks.
I want to live in the world that surrounds us rather than trying and construct one from scratch.
We saw this as emerging from inside the
world and carrying the world along with it.
In 1988, AMIX was acquired by the softwaregiant, Autodesk.
A growing scene of young technologists came together around Salin and The High-Tech Hayekians,
all working towards a common vision of enhancing human
freedom through networked personal computing.
It was this hot house of ideas
from which a worldview was brewing.
Salin died of cancer in 1991. The same year that
the World Wide Web became publicly available.
But his intellectual contributions andconflict with May had laid the groundworkfor what would come next for the cypherpunks,
the long effort to build a self-sovereign andanonymous form of digital money,
and the embraceof a branch of mathematics called cryptography,
which they came to view as the key to
personal liberation on the internet.